let's talk about the story we got from
the new york post fbi brass warned
agents off hunter biden laptop due to
2020 election according to
whistleblowers fbi officials told agents
not to investigate first sun hunter
biden's infamous laptop for months
vowing at the bureau was quote not going
to change the outcome of the election
again according to whistleblower claims
made public by uh wednesday by senator
ron johnson these new allegations
provide even more evidence of fbi
corruption and renew calls for you to
take immediate steps to investigate the
fbi's actions regardless of the laptop
johnson wrote in a letter
to justice department inspector general
michael horowitz according to the
senator individuals with knowledge had
told his office that local fbi
leadership had slow walked the laptop
investigation after the computer was
recovered from a wilmington delaware
repair shop in december of 2019
we got this story from the examiner jim
jordan says more fbi whistleblowers are
coming forward every other week here's
where it gets crazy
the fbi said not to investigate very
serious crimes which literally involved
the man running and there and and the
excuse was we don't want to interfere in
election it's like no you're literally
interfering you're you're pausing your
job
not bringing criminal justice
accountability to a corrupt family
because the person's running for office
at the same time right now donald trump
who we all know is going to be running
is having his home raided by the fbi and
they're cheering for it so very clearly
i just can i just what's the what's
what's the word for you know when we've
done uh hundreds of shows
thousands of segments and we just talk
about political civil war conflict the
weaponization of the doj all of that
stuff and like this
is it certainly should be
a a cold splash of water in the face of
the average person and if this doesn't
do it for you like to somebody and they
don't believe it there there's no
there's no change in their minds you
actually have the fbi whistleblower
saying we were told not to investigate a
hunter biden laptop which includes joe
biden
meanwhile donald trump currently right
now is having his home rented okay there
you go it's busted what do we do
we're do what we do which is i pledge
pointed out doing nothing is a form of
doing something often sitting by and
watching evil take place is an active
thing you do so
they certainly influence the election by
not getting involved or by choosing to
ignore it that's a form of influence
like it would be if uh let's say there's
a house
on fire
and uh it's got evidence of a crime in
it and the firefighters are like
i'm not gonna put that fire out because
then somebody might find that evidence
and use that against the person who
lives there so we just let the place
burn down i guess that makes no sense
the fbi they're law enforcement they're
supposed to say we will stop criminal
activity this means
hunter biden could have been actively
engaged in criminal activity
for a year
and the fbi was like well you know but
you know joe biden's going to run for
office so we better just let him do it
there you go welcome to uh
what's what's what's the word for it
what do we what do we call this era in
american history
is there a word we can use i don't know
i don't know i mean it's just such a
like partisan play right we don't want
to influence an election depending on
who's running and also who we don't want
to run it's just so strange and open i
am surprised that the fbi uh
isn't
i was really surprised when the obvious
answer after mar-a-lago was people
people being like we don't know that we
trust the fbi why are we letting this
organization run this way and the
response was no you can't say that about
this giant government institution like
it seems like it's clearly
biased to favor democrats right now and
to protect democrats who might be uh
conducting or
acting illegally but obviously par
choosing to investigate trump and other
republicans it's just
how can you even trust the system when
it's so obviously biased but they don't
care no they don't i think
what they're really trying to do is
protect the liberal economic order which
is this global
you know
thing we've had since 1946 basically to
prevent world war three they and whether
i don't think it i i don't personally
think it's like a democrat republican
thing i think they're trying to hold up
the old order i i i disagree somewhat i
i agree that there are powerful
interests and entities that clearly want
the liberal international economy to
stay afloat but uh you know people are
chatting about sam harris as a good
example of exactly what is going on here
sam harris he said the quiet part out
loud
he and then he tried walking it back
because he realized what he was saying
what he was admitting to
he said he did he would not care if
hunter binded the corpses of children in
his basement it's like you realize who's
giving this guy money and who's funding
this and like what that investigation
would actually lead to but they don't
care
this is this is
they're psychopaths i i don't know like
what's what's the mental
uh trump derangement syndrome is is that
the the official diagnosis you have
people who are like
sam harris literally saying hunter biden
could be abusing and murdering kids but
trump once once had a university and
that's worse he actually said those
words he said i wouldn't care if they
were corpse of children 100 biden's
basement
what trump did with trump university was
way worse than anything he could hunter
biden could have done and it's like what
like the worst case scenarios trump
opened a fake university and ripped some
people off and that's worse than joe
biden funneling u.s taxpayer money to
ukraine and getting us involved in war
and surrendering in afghanistan among
other things um
among a few other things i mean so you
asked what is what is this this period
in america's history called it's the
attempted hopefully attempted color
revolution of the united states weimar
america i mean well one wishes actually
it's worse than that it's it's exactly
the same kind of thing they pulled in
ukraine a couple you know like 2014 or
whatever we're talking about
a revolution they are
attempting to take over
the country illegitimately i would
opinion yeah and what i was saying uh
earlier is uh you know i've talked about
civil war but i should revise that
because civil war implies two factions
competing right now it just looks like
it's a revolution so you you know you
look at soviet russia you look at
germany those those were not civil wars
the political conflict ultimately
resulted in one faction just instantly
winning without a civil war so
to be a bit more pessimistic the result
of everything that's going on would be
revolution but i i do kind of feel like
they're losing so i do too and so i mean
another way that we could characterize
this since you have me here and i talk
about marxist theory all the time
is that what we're actually living
through is kind of the the logic of this
essay from 1965 called repressive
tolerance i bring this up a million
times i brought it up here before but
the logic of repressive tolerance is
that the left must be tolerated at any
this is actually you can look up the
essay itself it's the thesis statement
we must extend tolerance to the left we
must not extend tolerance to the right
they say that this includes the level of
violence marcus herbert marcus is the
one who wrote this in 65 he said you
know it's never ethical to engage in
violence but since once when does ethics
make history and so he excuses violence
and he has a long paragraph where he
mentions violence like 13 times and he
says there's a big difference between
revolutionary violence and reactionary
violence and what the deal is we must
extend tolerance to the left and not to
the right and he says to the point with
the right that what you're actually
trying to stop and this is the hunter
biden story right what you're trying to
stop is the thought from entering the
potential reactionary's mind
he says that it involves not just
censorship but pre-censorship you don't
even want the right wing which is
everybody who's not a revolutionary on
the left is the right wing by the way
you don't even want the thought to enter
their mind that would allow anything
except left-wing power to take control
and so we live in the logic of that
essay
i would guess that our department of
justice and our fbi have taken this
horrifically totalitarian document from
the 60s as an instruction manual and
what you see then is you see this uh
cracking down on president trump which
by the way i was on a flight recently to
california i'm sitting next to a
lifelong she's in her you know 70s
lifelong california liberal
married to her professor the whole thing
right so you're thinking some left as
she starts talking about trump she's
like well first she asked me what i do i
say i go around i talk about marxism i
study marxism she's like i don't know
anything about marxism i'm thinking
that's why you probably support it
but
she says that she's asking me do you
think trump trump's a dictator i think
he might have been an attempted dictator
this whole thing and then she says but
this raid on his house was too far
so you talk about shaking people loose
and freaking people out she was like
this isn't what we do in america
like they shouldn't have raided his
house and i was like wow that's
something now i heard a podcast with
like a literal neocommunist one of the
people that's in league with that
literal neo-communist that aoc shared a
megaphone with after uh samara taylor or
whatever name is after the roe v wade
decision and um
this podcast was with an educator who's
also an open communist henry giroux who
like changed all of american education
to be what it is today and in that
podcast she's like the very fact that
they raided his house
means that there must be evidence that
he's done all this wrong stuff and i was
like wow the dividing line in our
society is people who think the
institutions are still legitimate like
sam harris and people who don't
uh who who have questions at least about
them well so i often uh i eschew the
left right paradigm in fact that's what
my wikipedia says about me
and then uh you know people argue but
tim talks about the left and the right
all the time and i'm like they're
colloquial terms that don't really
reference politics they reference
as i think you put it well revolutionary
and i don't i don't think reactionary to
be completely honest because um
there are reformers right right you know
with the
the the leftist view everybody except
themselves as from his reactionaries is
right and literally it's like right-wing
extremists which of course we hear from
our military we hear from
uh the doj et cetera i often uh say it's
the those who are discerning and those
who are not
simply put there are people who will
hear information and say i'll check into
that and there are people who hear
information go whoa
crazy yeah exactly that's crazy and so
then you end up with um
michael brown and they go whoa
that's chris and then we go what's the
report say oh the report says hands up
don't you it wasn't true then you get
people who are like jesse smilet
whoa
and then we're like okay that sounds
nuts like right away when the story came
out we were like dude
trump supporters at 3am in sub in in
freezing weather in chicago in a work
district not a residential one attacking
a d-list celebrity i really don't
believe i stayed in that hotel in
january it was like eight degrees i had
covered it was awesome
that's great it was no sorry it was like
minus eight degrees let me no nobody's
getting attacked there let me give you a
really good example actually and um i
wanna i wanna shout out to our our good
friend vosh actually and um that's only
half vashti nova right yeah it's only
half sarcastic i do respect that he was
willing to come on the show though we
disagree with him but he tweeted i
delayed paying off my student loans just
in case debt relief got passed and now i
find out you're not eligible if you're a
famous youtuber who makes one million
dollars a day honestly and he's
obviously joking so i responded with omg
this is exactly the left vosh is rich
and wants free money this is proof biden
is a communist very clearly we are both
just being silly but
wow the responses from people who
instantly believed i was telling like
there are people on the left who
believed vosh was being serious and
they're going he makes a million dollars
a day and there are people responding to
me and they're like look at these
right-wing grifters look what they're
saying and it's just like that's it
right there did you know if he gave a
million dollars a day to people then
america could be everybody could have a
million dollars that's right he's the
one stopping you you know it's all
voucher's fault you know what i love the
most though is when someone says like
they're like
what do they say um michael bloomberg
spent 500 million dollars on the
election there were 300 million people
living in this country he could have
given everyone a million dollars like do
your math again
millions as a unit 16.
right now you have 10 eggs and everybody
could have eggs
millions is just a unit yeah it's simple
and so this is you know so to go back to
your point
you know you're mentioning it's the
people who trust the institutions people
who don't it's like yeah that's that's
all part of it um i refer to it as a
cult it is a cult it's 100 a cult i
would love to talk about how like not
just religious but cultish uh this whole
like
whether we want to do with woke whether
we want to deal with like this kind of
like leftist arrangement cult like sam
harris has i would guess i don't know
i've been out with him but once but i i
can't guess his mind but i would suppose
he has a group of people to whom he's
very interested in maintaining their
esteem yeah and there are
let me tell you as you would also be
able to tell people there are certain
things that you just can't espouse and
then before people decide they don't
like you anymore like people just they
think you've lost your mind they think
that you've uh that you're a terrible
person they disassociate from you and
but that's mostly on the left like it's
a liz it it's just on the right for sure
a little bit but i mean it's the
exception how did one get here
is that right yeah so you know i've been
cut off i've been i've been cancelled
from all kinds of people people i
thought were friends but you know all
sorts of stuff because well what did i
do all right i said that maybe trump is
an all right
candidate for trump isn't that bad maybe
orange man good you know who knows
maybe making america great again is a
good idea because it's kind of a on the
decent right now if we don't kind of
curb some of these things i i was uh
you know i i've been
talking about music lately because we're
releasing this song and uh it's fresh in
my mind so for those that are wondering
it's like why is tim bring it up again
well it's like it's in my mind we're
working on this project and i tweeted
this today like
there are people who are scared to say
things they like and that's weird to me
so nickelback is a really good example
um because everybody jokes about how
awful nickelback is it's like dude they
have ten six top ten i'm sorry they have
six top tens on billboard hot 100 and
they have one billboard hot 100 number
one for four weeks for one month they
had a song on the number the number one
song like people clearly like nickelback
yeah but it became a meme where i was
like you weren't cool if you admitted to
liking them well that's because they
weren't huge
maybe but i'll say this you know so i
was like
people clearly like them not really my
gem i've never been like a fan of them
but i but they did a cover of devil went
down to georgia which is mind-blowingly
good it's one of the best covers of the
song i've ever heard the guitar playing
is crazy the vocals are fantastic
they cut the chorus out though and i'm
like
come on man charlie you know charlie
daniels band it's a classic song but it
was really really good it's amazing i
got no problem saying that and there are
people tweeting at me being like this
explains it aha he admits it and i'm
like do you think i care i genuinely
enjoy that song i will tell you that
yeah i'm not worried about you not
liking me because you do nothing for my
life there's a term for this what is it
it's preference falsification
it's that in order to appear socially
acceptable you falsify your actual
preferences that you you like a
nickelback cover or song or band period
but you know that the people you're
talking to will think you're not cool if
you do that and so you falsify your
preferences as a that's crazy a social
maneuver that's crazy to me and i
actually think that people like sam
harris falsified their preferences or
maybe they didn't but maybe they just
got sucked in by the psyops but a lot of
people falsified their preferences about
trump to the point where they believed
it
like it drove him if you live in
crazytown for long enough you go crazy i
mentioned this the other day a couple
times a video of a woman asking three
women what is a woman and um i think it
was meant while she responded these
women all clearly know what a woman is
but they're trying to reconcile the
definition with what they're allowed to
say that's right yeah so it's like
definition falsification or something um
a lot of people miss by the way the big
point of what is a woman a lot of people
don't understand what that's about and
just to point out
kentange brown jackson actually told us
when marsha blackburn caught her out
said was a woman she said oh i don't
know do i look like a biologist or
whatever it was she said exactly about
invoking an expert what she said is i
can't answer that question without
asking an expert yeah in other words we
can't answer simple questions about
reality without an expert telling us
what the right answer is and that's
scary as hell because that's super power
grab territory
right and that's exactly what they are
are doing by by undermining definitions
by undermining people's ability to say
what's real and not real or you know use
words and have them mean things you
mentioned this woman on the plane right
you're saying yeah and she said the raid
on trump went too far yeah i'm wondering
if there's a point where
you know sam harris let me let me slow
down go to sam harris
he's got the most severe tds i have ever
seen
that woman does not she's probably a
normal person and just passively absorbs
information and thinks trump is bad
because she's just hearing it but then
when she hears something crosses the
line she made up her mind that's too
much for me sam harris told us there
could be corpses of children in the
basement of hunter biden he wouldn't
care and he compared him to an asteroid
that's going to destroy the earth
and that's like the next that's that's
lunacy like like not not only is that
just on its face laughably crazy but
even if trump really was hitler and like
the worst dictator possible would never
amount to an asteroid
smashing into earth and wiping out all
life as we know it yeah like bad
dictator bad we deal with bad dictator
certainly is not an asteroid coming to
wipe out the planet right through its
core and blow it out he's speaking in
hyperbole for sure i mentioned to you it
seems like he has like either or he
needs friends or he's got a group of
insulated friends and he's in an echo
chamber he needs like people to listen
to him and tell him when he's being an
idiot
sam you went too far that you i know you
were being hyperbolic when you said that
stuff i i i
was like he would have cared if hunter
had kids in his basement of course he
wouldn't hyper being hyperbolic is like
exaggerating something to prove a point
whereas like
that was a really strange thing to just
state like i don't think that qualifies
as hyperbole because i think he's being
honest what was happening he said i
wouldn't have cared if if hunter had uh
chill dead children in his basement i
would not have cared in brackets as much
uh or i wouldn't have cared i i think
it's simpler than brackets i see what
you're saying but i think it's simpler i
think it's you mentioned he's got he's
got a group of people he's trying to
pander to he's doing this public
interview he wants them to hear it
whoever they are and so he has to keep
one upping his position he has to be
bigger stronger better and in this line
of thinking it's trump is bad we must
stop trump by any means necessary in
order to pander to those people he has
to constantly expand upon his position
now he's at the point where he's like
dead kids don't care huh just got to
stop trump he's an asteroid it's kind of
like how incrementally the nazis started
first they didn't like jews then they
started taking their businesses away
then they started shipping them out then
they started shipping them to camps and
they started killing them like how it
incrementally got worse and worse so the
same with sam's mind seems to have
incrementally according to what you're
saying imagine people in politics or the
fbi doing that and this is the story we
have the fbi going like well we can't go
after hunter oh but donald trump he had
documents even though he has you know
you know like unilateral
declassification powers yeah you said
did you see the thing that he that they
put out that huge list of items and one
of the things that was contraband was a
was a i guess an illegal cocktail napkin
from the white house yeah they had a
copy didn't know that clinton's like
move furniture out of the white house
like this was like one of the famous
things they had to return stuff to the
residents they had moved stuff out like
i don't know we're not supposed to know
anything about oh sorry thanks for
checking out this segment from the tim
cast irl podcast but if you want to
check out the full show live tune in
monday through friday at 8 p.m and if
you want more special access content
head over to timcast.com and become a
member your membership helps sustain
this company keep our journalists
employed makes this show happen and you
will get access to exclusive members
only segments of the tim cast irl
podcast and there's a massive library to
check out so again go to timcast.com or
tune in monday through friday at 8 pm
we'll see you all there
you